[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them it's the democrat's
fault
media Joe Scarboro you are a joke and
Joe
mansion you're a piece of trash that's
right I said it don't you think it's
kind of funny that they have the
Senators out the
Senators are out doing their little
media appearances Joe
Mansion Joe
mansion and Mullen or Mick Mullen is it
Mullen or Mick Mullen no Mark Mark way
Mullen that's what it is of Oklahoma
senator Mark Wayne
Mullen is out there dropping dirt on
Matt G
I think it's kind of telling that the
Republicans have the Senators out
dropping this trash don't you think
don't you think it's funny that the uh
Oklahoma senator is the one doing the
media tour of how scummy Matt gats
is and it's not coming from a House
member speaking of house members in
trouble George Santos's former uh
campaign Finance chair I think it's
campaign Finance chair something like
that she has been in indicted on federal
charges and is taking a plea deal that
means cooperation against George Santos
I wonder how long it'll
take for the Democratic governor of New
York to appoint a Democrat to that
District
seat only making it only making it
harder for for Republicans to select a
speaker apparently GE Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan is at the top of the
[__] list good good luck do it my
friends do it I'm telling you I I wish
that we could elect Donald Trump and Jim
Jordan to be the speakers of the house
if you want to know the honest truth I
mean Donald Trump is already controlling
the House of
Representatives why do you think why do
you think Kevin McCarthy is no longer
the
speaker the reason why Kevin McCarthy is
no longer the speaker is because Matt
Gat has piles of dirt on him and Trump
knows all of it all of it Matt gats
begged him for a pardon against all the
dirt that Matt gats has committed crimes
probably toing underage some of his his
sexed up underage girls across state
lines with drugs and alcohol and
everything
else that we know there's evidence of in
a vinmo account and Joel
Greenberg his little his little party
friend down in Florida who is sitting in
a federal prison for this sex
trafficking H I wonder if Trump knows
the dirt on gats and I wonder I wonder
if Trump is really pissed off that Kevin
McCarthy didn't shut the government down
like he wanted him to and I wonder I'm
just wondering if everyone really
believes that Matt Gant did this for
some sort of [__] run for governor in
the State of Florida are you kidding
me you think I mean Matt gats is a dumb
son of a [__] I'm not gonna lie he's a
dumb [__] but you think he's
dumb enough to think that he can win to
be the governor of the state of Florida
I mean even even the dumbest of the
dumbest Ronda santz can be the the
Florida government there is not a chance
in hell that Matt gats will
win a Governor's race in Florida or a
senate race or somehow he's doing this
to stuff his pockets full of money
I don't know if you know this about
mattt Gat but he's a silver spoon
[__] just like the rest of these
Republican
scumbags I don't know if you know that
that's a that's a really good fact to
throw out there that he's a little
[__] spoiled rich kid it ain't no
wonder he acts the way he acts and
reason why you want to [__] choke the
son of a
[__] when he does the stuff he does I
mean he's pissing off Republicans like
you can't believe but it ain't got
nothing to do with Matt gats it has to
do with the dirt that Donald Trump has
on him and Donald Trump needed one vote
one one person to bring the motion to
vacate Kevin
McCarthy and then all he had to do was
bully I don't know eight Representatives
he knew the Democrats weren't going to
do this [__] he knew the Democrats
weren't going to protect Kevin McCarthy
why would
they come on let's get real here stop
with the stupid [__] in the media
how this is democrat's fault the
Democrats did this because they didn't
ban with Republicans and then they want
to have the talking point that who
Democrats voted with Matt gats what are
you talking about Democrats voted the
same way they voted in January you dumb
sons of [__] the same exact way which
was no to a republican speaker that
seems [__] reasonable to me if you've
ever met I don't know a republican
lately seems pretty reasonable that
people would say I don't want that
person to as the leader I would almost
bet I would almost bet that there's not
going to be one Democratic vote for the
next Speaker of the House Republican
speaker in the
house if we get a speaker which
is I I mean I don't know if they can
even agree on a speaker can they you
think they're gonna you think they're
GNA put Jim I don't report sex Grimes
Jordan in charge of the house he can't
even manage to get indictments on Hunter
Biden other than some [__] gun
charges you know that right you know the
House of Representatives has the ability
to refer criminal charges to a
prosecutor are you aware of this I don't
know if you've seen
this they are they are able to
refer criminal charges I mean they can't
get anything on Joe Biden to impeach him
because they're [__] lying pieces of
trash but here's the thing if they
really had the evidence on Hunter Biden
which they do not they do not all that
bribery and all the for foreign payment
[__] that's all [__] Hunter Biden
received those payments legitimately
otherwise they give a criminal referral
to the special Council David Weiss and
David Weiss would charge him you dumb
[__] pluck your head out of
your ass
okay it's not all t-fall hat conspiracy
theory we're all still alive even after
the feema 5G qinon signal yesterday
we're still on
air
the other thing I want to talk about
here is Trump being a chicken [__]
because that's really the lead story
here on the Tony Michaels podcast today
which you should be listening every
single weekday I don't know why you're
not and if you are thank you very much I
also want to thank everyone who bought
me shots yesterday no I'm not hung over
this morning but I did have a few shots
yesterday I want to thank everyone
Andrea bought me some shots let's see
who else bought me some shots yesterday
I don't want to leave anyone out here
Andrea bought me a shot let's see who
else do we got
here I want to thank everyone for the
shots I really do it's important to me
that I thinkk the people who are in on
the Tony Michaels
grift oh people calling me a grifter
let's do that ah let's see I want to
give a thanks to Renee Lorenzo and
Melissa and also Benny Laur Lee Bart uh
Peter Gary Anthony why not let's go down
the list here George
thank you very much for all the shots
and all the support here on the Tony
Michaels podcast it keeps this
microphone on I can't do it without your
contributions whether you're just
sharing engaging showing up and and
watching the show for two full hours
you're buying shots adding money to the
swear jar becoming patreon members are
sending a vinmo chat so that we can get
your message up on screen it all helps
to keep the microphone on I am reliant
on you the shareholders of the show the
people who like to have the the
cathartic release of me yelling and
screaming into this microphone and
making the points that we need to be
making and one of the points of trump
being such a [__] chicken [__]
running away from this Civil Trial and
Tish James in New York is hilarious now
for three [__] days this little
petulent child has come out and bitched
and whined and moaned and bitched and
whined and moan owned and you know what
it all fell flat in this country do you
want to know why this has all fell flat
in this country his whining bitching and
moaning other than the cultist who are
going to be with him no matter what
because of the delusion my guess is is
that his political campaign to told him
to get the [__] out of New York and stop
saying that [__] in front of a camera
stop saying the [__] that you're saying
in front of a camera it's not Landing
very well in the country do you want to
know why it's not Landing very well in
the country there's a lot of people in
this country that are struggling to make
their house payment they're struggling
to afford groceries they're struggling
to pay back their [__] college loans
because this country lied to them for
decades and decades and decades this
country has lied to our [__]
countrymen our citizens here just go to
college spend all that money oh you'll
get a great job you'll be rich just like
Trump and this mother [__] for the
last three days has been standing in
front of a camera
whining whining that his property one of
his properties in Florida in South
Florida is only worth $27
million whining bitching and moaning
that one of his properties is worth
$27
million more money than most Americans
their entire families their entire
families will make in a [__] lifetime
folks do you want to know why this [__]
is landing flat in this country do you
think people feel sorry for Donald Trump
because his property is worth $27
million get the [__] out of here with
that [__] and honestly I hope Donald
Trump gets in front of a microphone from
now until next November and why and
[__] and moans about how one of his
properties is only worth $27
million you see how it's Landing flat to
people who don't give a [__] about
politics right or do I need to spell it
out because I will spell it out for Maga
the maglites who do mag Magics and speak
vicomes fluently let me spell it out to
you why the American people are [__]
fed up with Don Donald Trump whining
that his property is only worth $27
million let me spell it out to you there
are people out there in this world that
do not give a [__] about politics
frankly they've given up on politics
which is the wrong road we need to be on
if you want to be quite honest but
they're more worried about what the hell
their paycheck's going to be next week
and Who the hell's going to be throwing
the football on
Sunday it doesn't make a lot of sense
because everything's politics and
everything in our culture and our
society is politics
but that's just where we're at in the
world in 2023 that's reality we cannot
ignore it but let me tell you something
when Donald Trump is out there trying to
get the American people to pay attention
to him and feel sorry for him because
his property is only worth
$27
million can you imagine can you imagine
the average working
American having their house be worth
only 27 million dollar you piece of
[__]
[__] think about it use your [__]
heads this guy is a goddamn fraud not
only that he's a whiny little [__] and
he's falling flat on America's
narrative he wants to tell America that
he's gonna come in and save you and he's
gonna make everything y you're gonna be
so rich remember that [__] only I can
fix it I'm gonna make you so rich you're
going to be so [__] Rich you remember
that how rich were you how rich were you
[__] how rich were
you were you so rich that you were
standing in front of microphones and
cameras to [__] about how your house is
only appraised at $27
million do you know why I'm so confident
that this country is absolutely going to
dunk that [__] in the God damn
trash is because of that he's not one of
us he's not an average American he's not
a blue call Blue Collar billionaire he's
not a he doesn't support unions he
doesn't support workers he doesn't
support the middle [__] class he
doesn't support migrant workers in this
country who come here and make a living
and generation after generation live
here hell half our [__] audience
their families came here two generations
ago
probably you don't think that [__] lands
flat in this country get the [__] out of
here with that [__] nonsense the only
people that believe his [__] [__]
are his [__] cult
members [__] him [__] him [__] him let
him take Jim Jordan let him make him
speaker when your [__] opponent is
drowning you hand those [__]
and anvil as James Carville
says get them [__] them let them have
what they want let them destroy their
party let the country see who these
[__] are the George Santos
party the Donald Trump oh man h i my
house is only worth $27
million feel sorry for
me you think that [__] plays well in
the
country that [__] vicy [__] and your
victim [__] is that your house is oh oh
my God 27 think about 27 million think
about it folks think about
$27
million what would you do if someone
gave you $27 million tomorrow hell let's
go with the lower price the 18 million
that he keeps talking about1 18 million
$18 million what would $18 million do
for you and your family huh what would
would it do for you and your [__]
family [__] what would it do for you and
your family for the next six Generations
huh it's time it's time we get right
with this [__] it's time we say what we
need to say [__] them [__] the media
[__] Joe Scarboro [__] Joe Mansion [__]
the Republicans [__] anyone who's
blaming this [__] on Democrats it ain't
Democrats fault that Donald Trump is a
fraud it ain't democrat's fault that
Republicans are [__] capit relating
to this goddamn child it is not
democrat's fault that they elected Kevin
McCarthy as Speaker it is not democrat's
fault that they're going to [__] try
to get Jim Jordan or Donald Trump to be
their speaker that's not democrat's
fault Nazis are GNA Nazi that's what
they're going to do folks that's what
they're going to do there ain't a
goddamn thing we can do about
it no matter what no matter what the
Democrats do and why the [__] should we
save them why in the hell should the
party that gives a [__] about governing
and democracy save the party that isn't
why give me one [__] good reason why
we should do that there's an election
coming up oh oh in just over a year just
over a year we're GNA make this decision
folks we're GNA
decide that's when we're going to decide
who to put back in power based on what
their [__] previous experience
is so go ahead go ahead you [__]
idiots continue with your delusion and
continue to do this stupid [__] in the
House of Representatives it is only
going to ensure that levelheaded people
go to the polls and vote against your
dumb
asses and if you think if you think it's
a winning message that Donald Trump's
going to propel himself to the
presidency again because oh man my
property's only worth $18 million
do good good luck with that
message good
luck the other thing that they're
terrified of terrified of
Republicans is this RFK Jr thing oh my
God it is sinking deep inside their
psyche it's the other reason why Trump I
think ran away from New
York because he is losing the plotline
here he's going to be the nominee they
don't have a choice now he controls the
Republican party up one side and down
the other I don't know if you noticed
what happened in the last week but he
absolutely owns the Republican Party
owns
them Lock Stock and Barrel the whole
entire [__]
thing they can't wiggle their way out of
trumpism
Kevin McCarthy is not speaker because
Trump is pissed that he kept the
government
open he used what dirt he had on Matt
Gat to get Matt Gat to come and bring a
motion to vacate that seat so that he
can put someone he wants in power so
that they will shut down the government
Because he believes in his [__]
diluted little
mind that somehow shutting down the
government will stop prosecutions and
will somehow destroy the economy and
it'll be blamed on Joe Biden and he will
win to be president of the United States
this is literally his
strategy this this is
it that's his strategy it is obvious he
is predictably
unpredictable and his strategy is to use
the House of Representatives to do
whatever he can to be the president of
the United States even if it means he
has to step in to be
speaker which again do it do it [__] go
be speaker oh yeah [__] yeah show the
world how worthless you
are as you're moaning and bitching about
how your property is only worth $18
million I'm sure I'm sure that average
Americans out there that are
struggling paycheck to paycheck even
though they're making more money than
they ever have that's right they're
making more money than they ever have
corporations are oh my God they're
swimming in profit
swimming in profits while average
Americans suffer while average Americans
struggle because most of the [__]
inflation is Corporate inflation
anyways it's all [__] it's not real
inflation it's them gouging
us and you're going you're going to tell
me that Americans are going to elect a
guy whining and bitching that his
property's only worth $1 18
million that's what you're telling me
you're full of [__] [__] media you're
full of [__] that you think this is neck
and
neck you're full of [__] [__] and you
wonder why Millennials and gen Z are
sick and tired of this [__] sick and
tired of people like Trump sick and
tired of the [__] media sick and
tired of people telling them that this
Bulls side [__] Millennials and Jin Z
are [__] tired of that that narrative
and that nonsense they know it not to be
crew somehow somehow somehow this
country has assumed that Millennials and
Jin Z have just had it so
great I don't know if you know this I'm
I'm almost 40 I'm getting there I'm
pretty goddamn close I'm 38 gonna be 39
soon here's the thing I'm one of the
oldest Millennials I'm like at the
oldest part of the Millennials we have
children who are about to go to college
okay we're not [__] children anymore
we're adults we have 401ks we have
retirements some of us some of us
[__] scrimp and save and put every
dime we can just to live in a house that
we have a mortgage on most of us do
not I don't know if you remember what
happened in 2008 I don't know if you
remember what happened in 2008 it was a
[__] it was a [__] and that was when
we became
adults KY the same
way some [__] out there have
been able to they own a house that's
worth a million and a half dollars and
in the
1980s they gave 16 cents and three
bananas for that [__]
house don't come preach to us about
[__] economic Strife you have no
[__]
clue our entire lives our entire lives
has been War since 2001 some fake ass
War for some fake ass reason
over in Afghanistan and Iraq lied to us
for 20 [__]
years Time After Time After Time we have
some [__] politicians in this country
telling us what the [__] we're going to
do who we're going to love and how
that's going to work out what books we
can [__]
read and you think and you think we
haven't seen
it and you're wondering why the the
millennial on the Gin Z generation looks
at Donald Trump the
embodiment the embodiment of entitlement
the embodiment of white
privilege bitching and moaning and
whining how his property's only worth
$18
million and you think you think that's
good messaging for Our
Generations why do you think Millennials
and jiny are going to line up around the
block to vote against that [__]
[__] huh why do you think what do you
think it could possibly be what do you
think it could possibly
be not to mention the [__] fascism
not to mention he wants to suspend the
Constitution I mean why could go on and
on and on and on he wants to give tax
breaks to the [__] rich just like him
which is the main problem that we have
in this country when [__] Grandpa
poopy pants is standing up whining about
how his property's worth $18 million
[__] him [__] him and [__] any person
who has that much Goddamn money take it
from him tax him eat the rich it's time
it's [__]
time oh Tony you're a communist well
well listen listen we're already called
radicals oh [__] [__] this morning Joe
mansion on Joe scarber's Morning Joe
MSNBC show him and caddy k at [__]
[__] [__] giving a platform to Joe
Mansion to busid
[__] laying out that it's it's
Republicans and Democrats that are
radicals get the [__] out of here
average working Americans don't think
it's radical to get a decent [__]
wage that's not
radical if you think it's radical to not
go broke because of a [__] medical
bill you're outside your [__]
mind in the richest country on Earth if
you think we should saddle people with a
lifetime of debt because the this
country tells them they have to get a
[__] education to not be a loser and
then they go pay for that [__]
education and oh my God they can't
afford but to be anything but a goddamn
loser and Donald Trump is bitching about
his property only being worth $18
million
put it in [__] perspective that
Americans will
understand and that's a goddamn
perspective that they'll understand you
find you find me one one [__]
out there that isn't struggling to
afford their mortgage or to get a
mortgage to afford their rent or to even
get rent in this country because of
[__] greedy bastards like
Trump who are whining he's whining
pissing and
moaning that they're only evaluating his
property to be worth 18 to$ 27 million
and that was their actual it's Trump
organization's actual figure I mean he's
a lying sack of [__] right it's a
[__] lie that's what Trump
organization actually [__] valued it
at1 18 to 27
million he knows that he knows he's
lying and he's not lying to us the
American people he's lying to his cult
members because they got to have man
they got to have something to talk about
they got to have a reason why Donald
Trump is the [__] victim here they
gotta be able to [__] be have it
translated in
victim let me tell you something keep
going you [__] keep going if
you think this is going to land well
with average Americans with maglites out
there these poor [__] toothless
rednecks who can barely afford the gas
to get to the Trump rally because
they've given him their entire [__]
life
savings to to to to defend him and to
pay his lawyer bills when he's not even
actually paying
them and and you're gonna have those
[__] broke ass
[__] those disgruntled
Americans who are who are mad for all
the wrong reasons at all the wrong
people they're going to sit there and
say oh yeah it's it's egregious it's
egregious that Donald Trump's house is
only is they saying it's only worth $18
million I've never seen $18 million in
my life I I wouldn't make $18 million in
my lifetime but it's it's [__]
ridiculous that Donald Trump's property
is worth 18 million that's
ridiculous good
luck I see where this is going F and
it's not going good for MAA or Trump or
Republicans and I'm going to keep
pounding the drum the way I pound the
drum and hopefully hopefully America
will
listen I'm hoping I mean you know I I
know you guys show up and you're the
best audience in the world but we're
going to have to add on to this we're
going to have to compound this we're
gonna have to double triple quadruple
this thing we're going to have to 100x
this
thing
and I know I'm Pat myself on the back
here but when American hears the
narrative that they need to hear they're
going to [__] get
right they're going to it may take a
while but they're going to I have
confidence people aren't this [__]
dumb there's some of them oh don't get
me wrong there's some of them that
really believed yesterday that all of us
that got vaccinated are going to die
because of a [__] safety
test cause FEMA is trying to test their
safety alert system to make sure when it
actually is an alert that it works to
save uh
lives ah you dumb sons of [__] keep
going keep believing your delusional
[__] and stop listening to the [__]
media would you stop doing that stop
doing that and I know more of my
audience more and more and more is
saying Tony you're right I didn't think
you're right at first I used to listen
to tyt and they're a bunch of bull bull
it's a bunch of
[__] it's a bunch of [__] I
don't have corporate sponsors I don't
got to [__] plate the corporate
sponsors I don't have Washington DC
breathing down my neck either they will
eventually oh they
will shut up please please shut up
please say it this
way no I'm gonna say it the way that it
needs to be said I'm sorry that's just
the way it's going to
be I haven't been invited to the White
House I haven't been inv invited to
Washington to Pal around with them I
wonder what it could
be they're scared of you that's why
they're scared of
you the powers that be are scared that
you will hear truth to power you will
hear it in a way that you're not
supposed to hear
it real and
raw they don't want a political iCal
movement against
them but we're here to save democracy
whether they like it or not doesn't
matter who it is whether it's Joe
Mansion or Joe scarber Joe Joe both of
you
Joe's pluck your heads out of your ass
man get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense Joe Scarboro you don't have to
pretend to be a republican anymore it's
okay and I know you want to pretend to
be a republican in front of Joe Mansion
who thinks he's a Republican and is
actually a demogrant I get that you want
to do that kind of [__] but America's
not going to buy that [__]
anymore somehow
somehow people wanting a decent [__]
wage people wanting to not goow broke
because of a medical bill people to want
to afford housing and
groceries to want to make sure that
their children get to start school at
three instead of five to make sure that
their children and their grandchildren
can go to college and not have a
lifetime of debt
now they're poting out in the Discord
chat that Joe Scarboro called Trump a
Nazi basically that's because of me I've
been calling them Nazis for three
[__] years three years I've been
calling them Nazis into the
microphone not stopping not [__]
backing away from it not beating around
the bush that oh well they're nail like
I mean no they're [__]
Nazis they're [__] Nazis that's what
they are that's what Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan is that's what Jim Qin
on comr is that's what Trump is that's
what Matt Gat is margorie Taylor
green good Mark Wayne Millan they're
[__]
Nazis I showed you a video
yesterday of a Merill candidate in
Franklin Tennessee near Nashville that
literally has
Nazis protecting her going to public
events I know I'm long on the first 30
minutes here but this is
important literal
Nazis it's time this country hear a
narrative that is g to shake it
Loose it's time this country stop
listening to [__] corporate-backed
media who wants a nice sugarcoated
[__] message of both sides there
ain't both sides in this country anymore
there used to be I hope we get back to
the buid [__] it would be really cool it
would be really cool for one party and
the other party to be compromising on
what the minimum wage should be so
Americans can get a decent [__] wage
in this
country instead of going on and on and
on and on and on about lies about Hunter
Biden's
dick on and on and on and on and on and
on about the crime that is obviously
been committed by the former president
of the United
States and capitulating to that [__]
petulant
child whining and bitching and moaning
about how much money he
has it's time we have a [__] movement
in this
country
it's time we show them what the [__]
we're made of and I don't give a [__]
who it is I don't care who it is I don't
care if it's mainstream media that we
get them right I don't care if it's
Republicans I don't give a [__] if it's
the Democrats eventually that needs to
get right I don't care if it's tyt David
Pacman or whoever else on the left that
sucks at this pod Saves America you
can't get more elitist than that can you
do you know do you want to know why
middle average Americans get turned off
by the left people like pod save America
I hate to tell you that I hate to give
you the facts but that pisses them off
that people like that tell them what the
[__] they're supposed to believe when
they already believe
it the reason why my messages stick so
hard it's not because I'm I mean I am
good at this but that's not the first
reason it's because I am just normal
average
[__] I'm not silver spoon I'm
not some political operative that ran
with a presidential candidate and ran
their campaign and worked in the white
house and was a staffer on the hill or
went to law school and got a law
degree that's why that's why the left
isn't Elite there's some of of them that
are just like on the right oh my God the
elitist on the right are overwhelming
they're everywhere Ted Cruz ivy league
Josh Holly ivy league educated Donald
Trump with the Wharton business
school he's a billionaire hell he's got
a house down in South Florida that's
worth a billion and a half dollars he
claims and he's not an elitist [__] out
of here with that
nonsense Discord they said we are all
Tony you're all me and I'm all you we're
one and the
same and we're pissed
off and a lot of people are pissed off
for the reasons they don't know why
they're pissed off and that's okay we'll
get through that we'll work do that
messaging we'll work do that narrative
we'll get there I promise you the rushin
ball the left me the rushin ball of the
left they've called me the wrestling
ball of the left will deliver us the
truth and we'll get there with the
narrative it's going to take a while but
it will
happen and we will continue to pound
this drum every single day Time After
Time After Time and I will do it with
the help of you the shareholders of this
show the shareholders of the
truth it ain't about [__] corporate
dollars it ain't about getting RI
it's about saving our [__]
democracy one show at a time and I know
that sounds crazy but how do you think
they got us in this position in the
first place how do you think Trump even
exists Trump is not the disease Trump is
the
symptom they used media to destroy this
country we can use it to save it I
promise you just make sure you tune in
every single weekday and don't stop
supporting even if you don't like me
that much even if you're like Tony yells
too much he says [__] way too much he
curses way too much ah [__] he says
those words and it gets deep down inside
my core and I don't like
it tough [__] that's that's what we got
to do we have to punch back we have to
fight for our like for our democracy
like we want it and it's time to do that
and we will do that every single weekday
right here on your show your show the
Tony Michaels podcast Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Facebook and twitch don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
Hardon blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup part
and blanket will protect you too part
and blanket is made of a sort of soft
fleece and a layer of sheep's wool and
they're 100% made in the USA don't delay
and get your pardon blanket today for
just
$999.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast oh we have some doubters over on
Twitch I'm glad to see it I welcome
desent here on the Tony Michaels podcast
I do not back away from descent I do not
back away from from being trolled a bit
even if you're in support of this show
and you disagree with me I think a
little bit of descent goes a long way if
you want to know the honest truth this
is where the rubber meets the road and
there's a few over on Twitch who just
had their doubts about The Narrative of
the rushim ball the left some are saying
Howard Stern some are trying uh to to
work this into a certain way they people
get really triggered when I say certain
things now this is important this is
important this is very important and I
know this phrase the rushin ball the
left has been a phrase that has been on
this show because people have called me
this since I was on Tik Tok and since I
started this show and the reason why is
because I modeled this show after
right-wing talk radio I don't know if
you know that I've modeled this show how
it sounds the the whole whole [__]
setup the whole thing the reason why it
sounds like radio the reason why I have
breaks is to sound like radio there's a
reason for that talk right-wing talk
radio is is the reason we're in the
situation that we're
in it's true it is the reason why we're
in the situation that we're in because
when you have politics politics is
boring ah it's F government is [__]
boring it's not sexy at all I don't know
if you've ever want turned on C-Span and
watched like house floor votes and some
of that oh my God this is the most
boring [__] in the world have you ever
watched a Committee hearing that didn't
have Republicans trying to
grandstand [__] like like hearings on
landfills oh my God so sexy government
is [__] boring it's supposed to be
boring if you want to know the honest
truth serious people doing government as
boring as [__] the most unsexy [__]
you've ever seen in your life okay it's
not
entertainment but Republicans and right
when talk radio
discovered something you know what if we
really dress it up and we really make it
entertaining maybe people will pay
attention and then once we got their
attention we'll [__] lie to them is
what we'll do we'll [__] lie to them
that's what we'll do we'll [__] line
to it I'm here to tell you I don't know
if you know this russling ball is one of
the great greatest radio talents this
country has ever seen he used all that
talent for vile evil
[__] okay okay that's what he did that's
what rush Lin ball did he had a great
talent and he used it for the worst
things that he possibly could do and he
set this country back he's part of the
reason why we have the disease we have
today that has caused trumpism that has
caused fascism to rise in this
country why is that why is that you say
Tony why is it well it's because of how
he did his show not what he said first
that's what everyone on the left gets
wrong I'm here to tell you that almost
every [__] on the left gets this
wrong they think it's what they say
first that
matters that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard in my
life you think that this culture our
society who loves reality TV I mean our
entire Society is now reality TV Society
you think it's the substance that they
like oh so full of
[__] you're full of [__] if you think
it's the substance that they
like it's the delivery
first
folks that's how it
works why do you think I yell and scream
I had someone comment the other day man
you can say this without yelling and
screaming there's a reason why I do
it I don't have to scream I don't have
to curse I literally cannot I could do
do an entire 2our sh and show and not
say one curse
word Mo maybe most people wouldn't even
notice actually the the loyal audience
would notice the people are here every
day would be like why in the hell hasn't
Tony said one curse word this entire
show it's really strange that he hasn't
cursed just one [__] just give us one
Tony it's all designed to sound a
certain WI
to deliver a message in a certain way
that moves the
needle I know I know I'm being more
transparent about this than what I
should be but I don't give a [__] I'm
not here to hide anything I'm not here
I'm not here to trick you into something
like the rightwing tricks their [__]
viewers like Steve Bannon tricks their
viewers every day Steve Bannon has taken
a hold of wrestling balls audience Steve
B is the most listened to right-wing
commentator which is [__] dangerous
as
[__] because Steve Bandon doesn't give a
[__] about Trump he do give a [__] about
trumpism honestly Steve Bannon is gonna
see huge amounts of money if if Joe
Biden stays the president of the United
States if you want to know the honest
truth Steve Bannon is rooting for Joe
Biden secretly he wants Trump to lose
badly because if Trump wins Trump's the
king not Steve
Bannon you dumb sons of
[__] listen it is about how you say
it first first and foremost it is about
how you deliver the
message and the left gets this wrong so
often every single day they get this
wrong they think they're going to turn
the country around on a 60-second clip
that goes viral with 18 million views
that is all a bunch of
[__] that's not the truth that is
not how narratives shift that is not how
paradigms
shift that is not how politics shifts on
one video going viral because boy it
really made the feels
good dumbest [__] I've ever heard of in
my
life do you want to know how narrative
shift do you want to know how politics
shift you want to know have Paradigm
Shift day after day after day after day
pounding the drum Shifting The Narrative
looking through the correct lens of
politics that's how it shifts that's how
we get this country back on
track and to think that media and
messaging and narrative and information
aren't the way to get us back right what
do you think got us in this [__] mess
in the first place messaging narrative
and
misinformation that's what what
happened that's how it happened now you
don't have to like the phrase russling
Bal the left you don't have to like it I
don't give a [__] doesn't matter to me I
didn't come up with the phrase I was
just called that and it sounded [__]
that sounded
poppy that sounded like it would piss
people off that sounded very very very
very visceral doesn't
it think about if you are a right-winger
there's some right- wiers in the
audience right now
right think about it there's some
right-wingers in the audience right now
think about how they feel about the
phrase the wrestling ball of the left do
you think it makes them
happy or do you think it pisses them
off I don't know you decide actually you
know what we're gonna let them decide
that's what we're gonna
do I'm not going to run away from that
phrase I'm not going to run away from
that
brand it doesn't make me any difference
if you get mad at me it doesn't make me
any difference if I piss you off frankly
that's what I'm trying to do is to get
you mad about [__] politics get you
to have some passion some feeling about
our
democracy to spring into
action people who get complacent don't
spring into action that's not how it
works I mean if I if I if this was
really a grift if this was a real a real
grift I'd have a corporate sponsor every
[__] 15 minutes I'd be doing ad reads
for stupid [__] like the the bun stopper
5000 we did that
one anything I could sell you I'd Ram it
down your [__] throats if this was a
grift
I'll tell you what the grift is here you
want to know what the grift is is to
move the
needle Jesus Christ if I was grifting do
you think I would sit here for two hours
a day and do a live show like I do it
when people on the left are like hey
look if you just do some clips and put
them up on YouTube and stop cursing Tony
you would make so much money and I
would if I listen if I just stop doing a
live show every every day two hours
today and I just concentrated every
couple days putting up a seven minute
video sprinkled in with some 60c Tik
toks on a YouTube channel I'd probably
have God knows how many hundred thousand
subscribers and I'd make all kinds of AD
dollars on
YouTube Oh Come man it would be [__]
fabulous it'd be [__]
great I can have more money than I could
spend in between those [__] videos
that I would make and boy I could really
really plate to YouTube's algorithm I
could do that too oh it would be awesome
I would give them the exact kind of
videos that they would want to to feed
to people who needed corporate
dollars so if you think if you think the
reason why I say and I embrace the
wrestling ball the
left it's only to get people to pay
attention
that's it that's what we need this is
your show this isn't my show this is
your show without you this does not
exist without the American people coming
and flocking to the show by by the tens
of thousands this show will not
exist this narrative will not
exist and yes I have to get crazy
sometimes I have to get
loud and I got to I gotta I got to to
point out the [__] real raw truth
sometimes even though it doesn't really
[__] feel that great to point it out
like yesterday they tried to make that
little CP of Joe Biden talking about the
Speaker of House that was that was not
good it was not good it didn't look good
they're making fun of him all over the
Internet when I saw it I was like what
is he saying what is he saying what is
he saying why did they put this clip out
on the internet like
that horrible narrative
horrible
we got a country to fight for we have an
ideology to fight for here it is
liberalism with a small L folks fascism
is on the rise not just here but all
around the world and they're not going
to stop at anything right now they're
not they're going to keep pushing
back they've lost the culture wars and
the only way to win is to embrace
fascism to embrace it they got not
Nazis protecting mayor candidates in
Tennessee you got Nazis in Florida Ronda
Santa supporters in
Florida on
overpasses they're going to drag shows
they're they want to exterminate our
countrymen the lgbtq community in this
country they want to exterminate
them and they're using every single
piece legislation they can do to do that
they want to get rid of the right for
women to have health care [__] they
don't want women in the military and
they don't want women to vote they
definitely don't want young people to
vote what do you think their goals are
huh you think it's gonna stop
there I'm in this fight with
you and again I only have one microphone
only one only one you have thousands
thousands of microphones and that's what
gives me optimism that's what gives me
hope that's what keeps me in front of
this microphone every single day that's
what makes me joke about the shots
that's what makes me thank you when you
have a venmo because without you I
couldn't do
it but because you're here and because
you believe in
democracy and because you believe in
this message there's a ton of people
that watch this show that cannot stand
that I say [__] as many times as I do
and I don't know if you noticed but in
the last half hour I haven't cursed that
much I don't need to
curse I don't have to get
loud but would you guys come here every
single day if I sat here and Tony
Michaels talk like this and said well
there's a story in the Washington Post
on page three let me give you the fact
facts in the background to give you a
good sense of what or what the narrative
should be and why both sides are the
same and why Joe Biden is not going to
win because of what Donald Trump said
and why when the Republicans do
something it's bad for Joe Biden would
you actually sit here and listen to that
trash would
you would you you wouldn't sit here and
listen to me talk like
that no
not for two goddamn hours you wouldn't
sit here and listen to me talk like
that I try to be as authentic as I can
I'll give you an idea this morning I was
talking to someone on the phone and we
were talking about this situation where
Donald Trump fled New York because he's
a little
[__] and how he was pissing and moaning
about how his property's only worth $18
million I was yelling and screaming at
the top of my lungs this morning on the
phone with this person they agree with
me we weren't w't arguing they were
laughing I try to be as authentic as I
possibly can be there's sometimes I gota
you know noon Eastern 11 Central night I
gota do the radio voice thing you know
what I mean but that's that's just what
we got to do we got to do these things
to save our
country and I know it feels like well
Tony boy you're really patting yourself
on the back listen I am nothing without
you
you this is not me this is you
channeling your voice your feelings into
this microphone to pump it out into the
world to make people think to make
people get mad about what is going
on to make decisions in our democracy
about politics about our
elections it's not about me agreeing
with you or you agreeing with with me
every single [__] time that's not
what it's about if we did that that we
would be it would be a big ass circle
jerk if you want to know the honest
truth and we wouldn't get anywhere we
wouldn't [__] get anywhere if I just
told you what you wanted to hear to make
you feel
good I'm not here to make you feel
good I'm here to give you the cathartic
release of the [__] you know is wrong
and the [__] you know that's happening
and the lies you're being told no matter
who's telling them to
you I'm here to set it
straight and I don't give a [__] not one
[__] who tells me this is the wrong way
to do it I don't
care I believe in it I believe in you
because you believe in me and you have
shown me over the last two almost three
goddamn years that this Show's been
going that there's something about it
there's something about it that I'm
getting
right and you keep me
going not just the the the shots not
just the venmo chats or the or the
patreon and please if you can do that do
that that's what keeps the microphone on
literally that keeps the lights going
that keeps the internet
on you guys doing that stuff and I
appreciate every single scent that is
sent to do that you you don't know how
much it means to me that's why I I want
to thank everyone who sends that
stuff as much as I possibly can because
I'm telling you this is your show
yours because you fund it you contribute
to make this show possible without you I
would not be here every single weekday
it just wouldn't happen there's not
there's not enough corporate sponsors
that would that would want my message
out there the way that it's out there
they just won't they they're not going
to we might find a couple of them we
might find a handful of them that are
like you know what this guy he makes
sense he makes sense we're willing to
put our product on his show and I'm not
going to just feed you full of a bunch
of [__] it better be a damn good product
if I'm GNA say yes let's do
that because I believe in you just like
you believe in
me and we got another hour of this and I
got some clips to show you and I got
some narrative to
drive so let's get into it let's stop
with this wrestling ball the left [__]
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reach DC we was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
got plenty of slim GS and
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one in your absence I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I a even seen my
cousin bro in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show
[Music]
some
sponsors in the break Paul and Nicholas
thank you very
much for the contributions that's right
I'm giving shout outs and I'm giving
shout outs to my friend my great friend
Ty Ros she's here every day she says the
rushim ball of the left apparently uh
she does not want me to stop talking
about that Ty you're beautiful and I
appre appreciate you here being here
every day as well as I appreciate paet
Nicholas
Renee Andrea Lorenzo Melissa Benny laury
Bart Peter Gary
Anthony that's right you are you are the
sponsors of this show this is your show
and I am so happy to be here in the
second hour of the Tony Michaels podcast
as we are every single weekday Monday
through through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central don't for forget to hit that
subscribe button hit that some [__] hit
that some [__] did you see I I want to
play the uh the Jimmy kimmell clip that
[__] man Jimmy Kimble that's who
I'm talking about I no no no not because
I'm not saying his show he just
vehemently defends his copyright on
YouTube so when I show this clip they're
they're gonna [__] with my YouTube
channel which you know it is what it is
what the [__] am I supposed to do right
it's not monetized anyways because
YouTube hates my guts and sponsors hate
my guts so why not let's show the son of
a [__] right why not just show it so
let's do it um as you know CA Cassidy
Hutchinson is out on her book tour um a
lot of people like this book I've had
some people U call me and contact me say
they've read the book I have not read
the book yet I don't know if I'll get
the book I don't know if I need to get
the book to be quite honest with you but
she's on her book tour and she's on
Jimmy kemmel live and she talks about
the katch-up story because Jimmy kemel
asked
her if this dude was throwing ketchup
all the time let's listen how often did
the president throw ketchup at the
wall this was a
reg regular occurrence like you launched
the
ketchup so
he Donald Trump has a I don't know if
you know this or if anybody's this
is I don't maybe people know it he does
have a very potent fear of being
poisoned what did she say Donald Trump
is scared to be poisoned are you [__]
kidding me this guy man you talk about
self- [__] importance
right I mean a lot of people are scared
about getting food poisoning right when
you go to a [__] restaurant you're
like man this place is a dump and the
health department has almost shut it
down but the goddamn chili dogs that
come out of this place are [__]
delicious am I right you ever been to
one of those places you know what I'm
talking about where the health
department is trying to shut that [__]
down but they can't because there's a
[__] line around the block to get
whatever food they're serving because
they don't give a damn if there's food
poison in it it tastes good it's damn
good and it's worth the food poisoning
that's a different kind of poisoning
Trump believes that like Putin's going
to poison him or some [__] right but
listen to this listen he's so scared of
poisoning listen to this did not know he
he had a fear of being poisoned well now
you do uhhuh so he uses and prefers the
small hindes glass ketchup bottle
because he likes to hear his valy
whoever is serving him his meal he likes
to hear the pop when you really that's
why I thought his hands are so little it
seem
like oh so you thought you thought the
dude likes the little bitty the little
bitty ketchup bottles because he's got
the tiny hands but listen Donald Trump
would never open his own ketchup bottle
this is the same [__] I'm talking about
folks about the $18 million [__]
Mansion down in Florida that he's mad
that they're only saying it's worth $18
million right this is the same old [__]
act like he's some sort of average
[__] get [__] out of here he is
the a silver spoon Elite if there ever
has been and you know what he's actually
a [__] a government Welfare Queen
that's right I said it his entire family
fortune was built off his father Fred
that Nazi that's right his father was a
Nazi was built on the fact that us the
taxpayers gave Fred Trump the money
through HUD to build his shitty ass
[__] apartment buildings and then us
the taxpayer paid the people the tenants
in his buildings rent to him through HUD
that's right all the money that Donald
Trump and his family has is because of a
because of
welfare they received it through HUD
government spending the entirety of it I
mean not to mention that they didn't
want black people in their apartment
buildings they they did that [__] too
because his dad is the [__] Grand
Dragon of the
KKK they went to civil court over it I
don't know if you knew that yeah they're
they're they're [__] they're they're
racist in court they're racist [__]
goddamn Nazis but but Donald Trump and
his family are welfare Queens if there
ever [__] were one and they're
[__] elitist have you ever seen
pictures of him in his apartment in
Trump Tower which is only 10,000 square
fet by the way not 30 there's another
thing he's
bitching they're saying my apartment in
Trump Tower is only 10,000 square
feet he's whining about the fact that
his one of his residences is only 10,000
square
feet sounds like an average Working
America to me if you want to know the
honest truth CCH that was that's for
poisoning
huh do you think he got this fear of
being poisoned from all the Ex-Wives or
where or is it Russia I don't
know no I don't think Russia's poisoning
him this a sense though no so he uh but
sometimes it would happen once or twice
a week sometimes more that there
sometimes it' be a week or so lull but
then there would be a bad news story but
it wasn't just launching the food and
the plates and the porcelain at the wall
it was also sometimes just flipping the
table so that [__] once or twice
a week threw such a fit that he would
throw food or flip his table
over once every once in a while we'd go
a week we'd go a week where he wouldn't
throw a [__] hissy fit like a little
[__] petulant child and you know the
reason why Donald Trump would do this in
ain't I mean there's a lot of reasons
why this guy acts this way but it ain't
because he's an Aver American who would
have to clean up his own [__] mess
off the floor if he threw his food on it
just like you at home if you threw your
[__] food all over the kitchen floor
guess who would cleaned it up not the
servants not the
valet come on man come on this is
[__]
ridiculous again and again time and time
again how this narrative has hasn't
peaked out through this I don't know we
got some more sponsors here we got en
Reese with some shots we got uh I'm
gonna get this wrong so I'm gonna say
lot tulson Tolson uh with the
sponsorship there thank you very much
you guys are awesome you guys really are
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna throw
ketchup all over the wall when you guys
are sending shots
in I'm not scared of being poisoned by
shots I'm get dinged on that Jimmy
kimmell but it was worth it it was
totally worth it to um listen to that
Donald Trump is terrified of being
poisoned and then he [__] hates
people around him so much he hates his
servants and his valet and the maids so
much that he'll just haphazardly toss
food all over the floor because he's not
happy oh man he's not happy every time
let me ask you every time you get close
to the end of the month and you're
running a little thin on money
and that credit card bill's coming due
or the rent's coming due the electric
bill is a little higher than you wanted
because it's hotter than a [__]
and the air conditioner running like
crazy or the or or maybe maybe maybe you
had to buy a certain set of tires that
you weren't expecting maybe you had a a
mechanical something mechanical with
your car that you had to take care of
that you really didn't
foresee you know what I mean you know
what I mean and you get really pissed
off dude that that's enough to piss
someone off that's enough to really piss
someone off because when it rains it
pours am I right right am I right when
it rains it [__] poures but do you
throw your food all over the kitchen
floor I mean you want to you oh man
wouldn't it just be [__] nice have
you ever seen these what are they called
like rage rooms where they set up all
this [__] in this room and you get a
ball at and you just get to [__]
destroy everything you know just get it
all out of your [__] system you know
what I mean sometimes you just need to
get that [__] out of your system that's
why you come here really honestly
because I'm willing to yell and scream
and say the things that you want here
and get it out of your system
right but the reason why you don't is
because you don't have a maid coming up
behind you you don't have a valet to
come up behind you and open your ketchup
so you hear the little pop
right come on and we're supposed to
believe that this guy isn't an
elitist listen I understand that all the
presidents all of
them have a certain portion of their
while they're
president that is kind of done for them
cooking meals laundry like all that
stuff right that's all done for them
every president not just Trump but Trump
had this before he was
president Trump's been this way since he
was a [__]
child okay you got
it this is why his expect
of his victorial power is so
immense because he's been treated like
he some sort of Prince his entire
[__] life even though he's not even
close to royalty this guy's white trash
with
money he always has been white trailer
trash with money you ever met white
trailer trash I mean real there Hey
listen there are some great people who
live in some of the trashiest parts of
the country who live in some of the
shittiest trailers some of the shittiest
houses they're great people they give
you their [__] shirt off their back
and they even got the shirt to give
you but I'm talking about the dirt bags
you know what I'm saying and it doesn't
necessarily mean that they live in the
worst house in the neighborhood it
doesn't necessarily mean that they live
in a trailer they can live in the
biggest house nicest house the
neighborhood and they're [__] white
trailer trash they're pieces of [__]
look down upon people hate [__]
they're shitty neighbors you know what
I'm s you know what I'm saying you know
what I'm saying they're they [__]
walk their dog and let their dog [__] in
your yard and they don't pick it up
those [__] those kind that's
that's Trump that's Trump trump would
have his valet go walk his dogs if he
liked dogs enough which he doesn't he's
such an [__] Trump is such an [__]
that he doesn't even like dogs he didn't
like a [__] dog never owned a [__]
dog and he could have he could have he
could have his staff take care of the
dogs for him that's how much he hates
dogs think about that put that in
perspective that's how much that son of
a [__] hates dogs is that he wouldn't
even hire staff to take care of his dogs
but if he did he would definitely hire
his staff and want the staff to take the
dog down the street and [__] in your
yard that's where he'd want them the
[__] not in his
yard those type
[__] that's who Trump
is it's who he's always been he's a
piece of [__] okay so Scott McFarland
speaking of pieces of
[__] speaking of huge pieces of [__]
George Santos is back in the news
rutro H it looks like George Santos's
congressional seat is going to be in
Peril here alert Nancy marks the former
Aid to representative George Santos a
republican of New York otherwise known
as Anthony devolder has been arrested
and charged by the feds court filings
indicate a plea deal is in the works
apparently this morning n marks the
former Aid to George
Santos
is going to be pleading
guilty um it it seems like the federal
felonies um have to do with her being
the uh ex campaign Treasurer Hugo also
has it here prosecutors say ex campaign
treasurer for George Santos charged with
federal felony offense and will plead
guilty I'm not sure when the arraignment
is uh for Nancy Mars uh but I'm sure
it'll be in the coming days uh when
Nancy marks will actually plead guilty
uh so that now what this means and
Daniel Goldman had it here too I I
retweeted Daniel Goldman you guys know
the congressman Daniel Goldman Daniel
Goldman just a good Congress person he's
a damn good lawyer too there's very few
of those in this country these days but
Daniel Goldman said if P um pursuant to
the cooperation agreement which I
suspect it is is a very bad for George
Santos it likely means more campaign
Finance fraud charges to come so not
only Daniel Goldman is assuming here
that not only is Nancy marks going to be
uh charged and plead guilty to Federal
felonies due to campaign Finance fraud
but also George Santos because of those
guilty pleas will also uh be charged in
the superseding indictment um and we
know what superseding indictments are
from the documents case in Florida now
if you weren't aware of it before what
happens is is they do the original
indictment and and then they try to
force people to turn on a certain person
by not indicting them at first and then
including them on a superseding
indictment when they don't cooperate
that's how the feds do it like it's a
trick that they do I don't know if it
should be done that way but they do it a
lot and that's what Daniel Goldman here
is pointing out that that's probably
what they're doing is they're using
Nancy marks uh as a as a a a a a
cooperator with the federal prosecutors
here in the George Santos case
for the campaign Finance fraud charges
that are possibly to come with George
Santos so we we'll see if there's more
charges that happen on this uh Santos
indictment but with someone pleading
guilty it's going to be very hard for
George Santos to tell us why he should
still be a congress person now here's my
here's my two cents and I said this way
back when the George Santos narrative
started I said I don't want George
Santos to resign remember when I said
that do you remember when I said that
way back when and I said they'll have to
own George
Santos they'll have to own him the
entire time he's a republican he's no
different than any other Republican he's
no more of a liar than any other
Republican he just tells all the
Republican lies right see that's the
difference between George Santos and a
normal Republican a normal Republican's
like I'm gonna pick three lies and I'm
going to tell those Lies over and over
and over again George Santos loves all
the rep Republican lies like he likes
all of them so he just tells all of them
you know what I mean and Republicans lie
was such reck and Abandoned and they're
not ever held accountable why would he
not want to do this right am I right am
I right am I
right speaking a congressman in Peril H
Matt Matt vinmo gats was forced by
Donald Trump to um bring the motion to
vacate to the floor with this one vote
that's that's what happened I I know I
know it's in ational to say that he's
wanting to grift and he wants to make
money he wants to make a name for
himself but the real the real skinny of
it is is that Matt gats has a lot of
[__] underage skeletons in this
closet if you know what I'm talking
about a lot of underage skeletons in
this closet and Donald Trump knows all
those skeletons because Matt Gat
actually went to Donald Trump and begged
him for a pardon before Donald Trump was
ousted by us the voters um so Donald
Trump knows all that dirt
and I'm sure he was briefed by Bill bar
on all that dirt I'm sure Bill bar made
sure to
brief Donald Trump because Bill bar was
the one going after Matt Gat because
he's a [__] scumbag even Bill bar
even the scummy vile fascist Bill bar
knew that Matt gats needed to be gone
after by the justice department but I
find it really funny that people think
that that this Silver Spoon [__]
is doing this for money he's not doing
this for money you can see it in his
interviews he's terrified that if he
doesn't do this [__] that the truth is
going to come out about him now the
problem is is that the Republicans are
going to [__] destroy Matt gats no
matter what which is
fantastic oh my God so delicious I was
in a room the other night after the the
vote to vacate with Laura lomer you know
Laura lomer this crazy [__] loon you
know the one I'm talking about the one
that looks like she's had millions of
dollars worth of plastic surgery to have
gender confirming care that's right
Laura lumer Laura lomer has had gender
confirming Care on her face woo baby I
mean all over her [__] face I could
show you some pictures but I don't want
I I want to keep the audience that we
got over 2,000 people watching I don't
want people to get off the air by me
showing pictures of what Laura lumer
looks like here's the thing she was in
the Twitter space the right-wing Twitter
space with Seb Gorka and oh my God she
was torching Matt gats torching him oh
you [__] piece of [__] just like she
torches Marjorie Taylor green good good
I hope this MAA Civil War continues and
this morning and yesterday it continues
with Mark Wayne Mullen I got a couple
clips of Mark Wayne the senator from
Oklahoma which kind of funny see it was
the House of Representatives that
vacated Kevin McCarthy by matcats voting
uh are are setting a motion on the floor
to vacate that seat H probably by the
order of Donald Trump by threatening him
with the dirt that he has on him uh now
it just seems really suspicious really
sus that they're using a United States
senator from Oklahoma to come drop the
dirt on on Matt gats it's almost as if
the Republicans don't want someone
inside the House of Representatives
doing this huh I wonder what it could be
I wonder if it's
because Trump controls the house I
wonder if that's what it could be I
don't know but let's listen to Mark
Wayne here this [__] idiot talk about
the other idiot Matt gats let's listen
to him drop the dirt wasn't too long ago
that no one would even touch him because
he was being accused of of sleeping with
underage girls which honestly there was
no colleagues that came out and defended
him because quite frankly the stuff that
he would show on the floor and the stuff
he would brag about on the floor before
he was married we probably thought well
that's that's that's reasonable and we
okay so Mark way Mullen here I I want
you to hear this marway Mullen is saying
into into Trader TV news networks that
Matt gats was showing them child porn
underage porn that's my assumption we've
heard this before that Matt gats was
showing uh other colleagues on the floor
pictures of naked
girls and here Mark way M listen to it
again listen to it again there I'll play
it again that's what I'm hearing you
hear what you want to hear but I'm
hearing that's what I'm list even
touching because he was being accused of
of sleeping with underage girls which
honestly there was no colleagues that
came out and defended him because yeah
quite frankly the stuff that he would
show on the floor and the stuff he would
brag about on the floor before he was
married we probably thought well that's
that's that's reasonable okay so it's
reasonable to believe that Matt gats was
sleeping with underage girls based on
the pictures and the stories that Matt
gats was telling his colleagues so that
means that means not only is Matt gats
probably have underage porn on his
electronic
devices of underage women that he's been
sleeping with not my words these are not
my [__] words these are Mark Wayne
mullen's
words underage girls that he is presumed
to be sleeping with he's showing them
pictures evidence and telling stories so
not only has Matt Gat got underage porn
probably on his phone more than likely I
think that's what mullen's saying right
Am I Wrong to believe that that's what
he's saying he's talking about mcats
having sex with underage girls and then
them being shown pictures and stories to
prove it and they were like yeah sounds
about right I mean based on the pictures
the child porn so Republicans are
looking at child porn on the floor of
the house and not saying a goddamn word
I thought this was the save the children
crowd now come
on come on now are we supposed to
don't you see where this is going don't
you see why I was cheering for Matt
vinmo gats to vacate the seat of Kevin
McCarthy don't you see why I'm so
excited for the Republican party to
Madison Kor him do you remember Madison
gawthorne do you remember do you
remember Madison
goor shitler on Wheels you remember
that the guy in the wheelchair remember
the sex sex field cocaine orgies or no
excuse me the cocaine field sex orgies I
got that backwards do you remember that
they got rid of that [__]
because he was telling the
truth Matt gats is being C thorned here
but the problem is the problem is the
reason why the reason why Republicans
have been protecting gats this entire
time is because they were yucking it up
on the floor with Matt gats when he was
showing them underage porn of girls who
were underage that he was having sex
with and telling them stories they were
yucking it
up oh you don't you think they were
disgusted you think they were appalled
by this don't you think if they were
appalled that they would have sent Matt
Gatson to an ethics investigation
because he had porn of underage girls or
pictures of underage girls that he was
claiming had sex with on his phone on
the house floor these are not my
words these are Mark Wayne mullen's
words keep going Mark Wayne keep going
and burying the Republican party here
keep going dude and we would always have
to walk away from him uh and so this
individual that you have here I don't
think what he's done is is is something
to be expelled but this is something
that his constituents back in Florida
should make a hard look at oh oh you
hear that Mark Wayne cares so much about
about someone bragging about having sex
with an underage
girl that he doesn't think that's that's
enough for
expulsion well it's not surprising to be
quite honest Mark Wayne this is not
surprising senator from
Oklahoma because you want to force
underage girls to carry a baby because
their father or their uncle or someone
raped them yeah that's right he wants
12-year old girls to carry babies to
full term because they've been raped
it's the same piece of [__] so it's not
surprising that Mark Wayne Mullen here
knows the truth about Matt gats yucks it
up with him on the floor and then when
it comes down to Matt gats not being on
the same side as they need him to be on
now that they're gonna look the other
way and say well I don't know if he
needs to be
expelled expelled seems a little extreme
for a pedophile I mean that means I
would have to be
expelled
I mean how many Republicans would be
left in Congress if we expelled them for
their pedophilia huh it's always
projection with these [__] we
know that marway Mullen has [__]
confirmed
it he's confirmed it that they they
would yuck it up with him on the floor
and the the the very least they would do
when Matt gats would show them pictures
of underage girls that he'd had sex with
and telling them stories of underage
girls that he'd had sex with they would
just walk away from him they'd have to
kind of get away from him on the house
floor you know maybe meet him in the gym
or in the senate cafet or in the house
cafeteria that way he could tell the
stories
there they really are telling on
themselves aren't
they they really are telling on
themselves it is [__]
beautiful I can't tell you how [__]
awesome this
is I'm telling you fol folks I know I
know everyone thinks that oh man the
media is saying this is horrible oh my
God they're saying this is horrible this
is horrible for the damn
Democrats cuz
Democrats Democrats
Democrats [__] out of here with this
[__] here's more Mark way on CNN
with more of this [__] keep going Mark
Wayne keep going keep talking into the
[__]
microphone you got to think about this
guy um this is a guy that didn't have
that the media didn't give a time a day
to after he was accused of sleeping with
an underage girl and there's a reason
why no one in the conference came
defended him because we had all seen the
videos he was showing on the house floor
that all of us had walked away of the
girls that he had slept with he' Bragg
about how he would crush Ed medicine and
and and Chase it with um with an energy
drink so he could go all night this is
wh Whata what what what what what wait
wait Mark Wayne Mark Wayne are you
telling me that Matt Gat stood on the
floor showed you pictures on his phone
of underage girls that he had sex with
and telling stories about how he' take
viagara and drink monster and Red Bull
so he could so he could continue to have
sex with those underage girls all night
long and you're just now telling us
this where the [__] were you where were
you three years ago huh four years ago
where the [__] were you Mark Wayne were
you hiding underneath a [__] rock
I thought these people cared about
children I thought they cared about
children children this children that
cheing on this chewing on that we care
about the sexualization of children I
mean unless Matt gats is sexualizing
underage girls on the house floor while
he's talking about taking Viagra and
energy drinks so he can [__] underage
girls all night
long are you
serious are you [__] kidding me keep
going bro keep going obviously before
you got married and so when that
accusation came out no one
def oh okay okay okay all right no no I
I got Mark Wayne wrong there did you see
that did you see how I got him wrong
Mark Wayne explains to us this was
before he got married okay so it's all
okay it's all okay because it's before
he got married you understand you see
you see now it was oh man it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't the underage girls and
him having sex and the bagra right that
really got him you know that's the
reason why they didn't really bring in
ethics investigation against him that's
the reason why they didn't speak out
against him that's the reason why they
didn't call for him to resign after
doing that really the reason why they
didn't do that is because he wasn't
married yet he wasn't married yet so
that you know that makes it okay that
makes it okay in Republicans book and
then no one on the media would give him
a time of the day all sudden he found
Fame because he opposed that's all
[__] the media did give him Fame
you're so full of [__] [__] you're so
full of [__] and house members didn't
walk away from him that's a bunch of
[__] too do you remember Marjorie Taylor
green went on a national tour called the
America first tour with him and it
failed miserably Walter Masterson listen
there's a video I I I can go find it I
can go find it it's really easy of
margorie Taylor green and Matt gats even
after all this accusations were standing
on a beach in California because they
couldn't get anywhere else to host their
stupid little America first thing in
California and Walter went up and called
him a petto and they escorted Walter
away this idea that no member of the
House and no members of the House f
[__] was would even talk or give him
the time of days is a bunch of [__]
Mark Wayne here is full of [__] and
they're trying to destroy Matt gats but
they're trying to do it in a way that
doesn't [__] show their complicitness
towards him and it's not working not
with me the Speaker of the House back in
November and he's always stayed there
and he's not he was never going to leave
until he got this last moment of Fame by
saying by by going after a motion to
vacate it's important to know
Congressman Gates has never been charged
with any sex trafficking crime and he
gave now see this is the [__] that the
news media has to do oh man it's just
alleged it's
alleged come for me Matt gats come sue
me send me a cease and assist let's do
that let's do Discovery [__] on your
vinmo account let's do discovery on
these pictures that you were showing
people on the house floor like Mark
Wayne Mullen let's do that let's do
discovery on that s you're a [__]
pedophile you were [__] showing
underage girls pictures of underage
girls and bragging about having sex with
them on the floor of the house you were
doing
that come for me let's do the [__]
Discovery let's do that I'll do it
and then I'll counter seee your ass
let's do it Matt let's do it Maddie
prove me wrong remember you're such a
[__] tough guy you vacated the
[__] speaker do it [__] do it he
ain't gonna do it media scared of Matt
gats are you kidding
me [__] out of here I want to give a
shout out to KJ it looks like she
brought a bought a [__] them hat oh my
God it looks like someone bought a [__]
them hat that's right these [__] them
hats are for sale sale you just go to
the Tony michaels.com Theon michaels.com
go down to the merch the [__] hat store
is right there if you want to get a [__]
them hat it's a great support for the
show as well you don't have to just send
me shots or VMO payments uh for the VMO
chat so I put your message up on screen
you can get you some merch too there's
merch there there's [__] them hats
Everyone likes the [__] them hats
there's several different types in the
store there so go get you one if you
want one thank you very much for the
support I'm going to keep giving shout
outs here I I think that's just how
we're going to do it since I have
sponsors to shout out I'm just going to
shout out you guys every time you guys
support the show so keep going keep
doing it I love you guys and we're going
to keep this going on mat gats um if I
can if he's doesn't resign and slink
underneath a rock somewhere okay I want
to show you a h here's a video of a
former Press Secretary of a republican
uh speaker Paul Ryan do you remember
speaker Paul Ryan let me give you a
sense so the last five Republican
speakers right the last five Denny
Hazard Denny Dennis went to prison for
um what's that oh yeah child sex he went
to prison because he was he was having
sex with underage boys and he had to
admit to it that that former Republican
speaker that guy that guy went to
federal prison uh for that uh and then
there was John Boehner that guy resigned
because they did the extremists didn't
want him anymore you remember that when
John Boehner resigned
not only resigned his speaker he
resigned his house seat and then they
couldn't find anyone to be speaker do
you remember that I don't know if you I
don't know if you remember this or
not they couldn't find anyone that
wanted the job to replace Boehner
because of the extremist this is before
Donald Trump folks this is before
Mega this is Prem Mega extremist they've
always been extreme they've always been
a cult keep telling you that they just
never found their cult leader until
Trump but they forced Paul Ryan to be
speaker Paul Ryan made a deal you know
what that deal was Paul Ryan made a deal
he said you have to take you cannot
vacate my seat it has to be 20 people to
bring a motion to the floor to vacate my
seat 20 that's what kind of stopped Gap
Paul Ryan wanted to be speaker because
he knew they'd get rid of him they he
knew it he knew it he knew then that it
was the extremist they hated Obama they
hated the black dude you know what I
mean oh my God the black guy became
president they just freaked the [__] out
the tea party you know what I'm saying
the freedom
caucus they really really really were
terrified of the black dude being
president it was a tough thing for them
it was a tough eight years for him you
know the birth certificate lie and all
that [__] it was really tough for him he
brought the country back from the brink
from the worst economic crisis since the
crash in 1929 since the Great Depression
he brought us back from the brink of
that and they really hated that they
they hate that Obama's given credit for
that the black guy oh my God they
[__] hate hate the black guy and then
and
then Paul Ryan decides he's not even
gonna [__] run again the guy is the
Speaker of the House third in line to
the
presidency third in line the third most
powerful person in the country if you
kind of want to lay it out like that he
decided he didn't want to be speaker
anymore not only that he wouldn't even
run as a congress person anymore that
was his entire personality Paul Ryan
Paul Ryan's entire personality was a
congress person he's another Silver
Spoon [__] he's another rich
little spoiled brat who became a
congressman in was his entire career
kind of like Matt gats kind of like
Donald Trump they're just spoiled little
[__]
right right am I right so Paul Ryan
didn't even want to be the speaker of
the house
anymore which he could be has enough
income from his family businesses that
he wouldn't have to be speaker of the
house so he gave up and now we have
Kevin McCarthy vacated in nine months
it's almost like a late term abortion of
a speaker of the house if you want to
you know kind of put it in the terms of
that Republicans would understand so the
last five speakers Republican speakers
those are the last five Denny Hazard
John Boehner Paul
Ryan and and Kevin MC am I missing one
I'm missing
one I'm missing one the point is this
the point is well the next one whoever
the [__] the next one is the point is
this is that they are such [__] [__]
boxes and they can't govern and the
reason why they can't govern is because
their party is dead oh yeah new there
you go Andrea points out new new was
before that's right that's the F new was
before this is hearkening way back oh my
God way back and they [__] hated n
Republicans got rid of new Gage because
n grid did the same thing that Kevin
McCarthy did same [__] thing made big
promises that he couldn't deliver on
knowing that he couldn't deliver on them
knowing that they were lies it was all a
bunch of
[__] no is all a bunch of [__] I
forgot N I thought n was dead I
apologize to n Gingrich I thought I
still is he still alive is he alive
today I mean he was alive yesterday I
played a clip of him but I don't know if
he's alive today I thought that guy was
dead anyways here is the former
Communications chief of
communications for Paul Ryan for speak
with Paul Ryan let's see what he has to
say about Republicans being in charge of
government again this is Republic
Communications adviser to speaker Paul
Ryan this does not get any better what
Dusty Johnson said is absolutely right
um we are not right now fit for
governing we are a party much more made
for being in the minority we like to
vote against things my whole issue with
all of these folks is their problem is
not really with the speaker of the house
it wasn't with Kevin McCarthy it wasn't
with Paul Ryan or John Boehner these
guys just don't like the realities of
governing there are so there you go they
can't govern they won't govern they
don't want to
govern their party is incapable of
governing and the reason why is because
they're fascist and they've given up
they've given up democracy they've given
up on the Republic because they can't
force us to do what they want us to do
in this democracy in this constitutional
republic for you maglites out there that
don't understand what constitutional
republ republics are and that what a
democracy
is they cannot govern they will not
govern it's a thing they can't and won't
do I mean they'll act like it here's a
great video of the acting speaker now
this is a real rendition
here of the acting speaker Patrick
McKenry let's let's hear from mat
Patrick McKenry chair declares the house
of recess subject to call of the
chair chair declares the house for
recess subject to the call of the
chair oh my God chair declares the house
of recess subject to the call of the
chair oh man I found that on Twitter and
I posted it and it went it went crazy uh
on Twitter so if you want you go here
let me let me retweet it real quick so
you can find it at the top of my feed
go grab that video and post it
everywhere I should grab it and post it
on the Facebook and other places oh boy
now I want to show you um speaking of
Elections and [__] narratives I told
you Joe Mansion was on Joe scarber's
Morning Joe this morning and Kim and
cadd K uh brought Joe mansion on and did
the typical bothside [__] with Joe
Mansion shame on you caddy shame on you
Joe Scarboro [__] you both [__] you both
[__] both of you for having Joe mansion
on and doing this Bulls side [__] [__]
you um but Joe Mansion they were talking
about how it's the Democrats fault the
speaker McCarthy is the reason why he's
not a speaker anymore and they did that
whole [__] thing where it's the
Democrats fault Democrats Democrats
Democrats Democrats are in the minority
you dumb sons of
[__] they're in the minority that
Democrats are not going to vote for a
republican to be
speaker not one democratic vote this
entire time January and over the and
over the weekend none of those votes
went to Kevin McCarthy because that's
not how any of this works they know it
but here they are talking about this no
labels [__] and let's talk about no
labels for a second and JFK Jr I'm G to
talk about this let's listen to this
[__] you know I I'm gonna show you
I'm not just gonna talk about the
[__] that they're spewing up on
Morning Joe I'm gonna show it to you
listen to this nonsense um the No Labels
uh people reached out to me and they say
we have one goal and our goal is defeat
Donald Trump oh well you know what the
No Labels crew reached out to Joe
Scarboro so that he could come on his
show and feed their audience full of a
bunch of
[__] huh isn't that funny isn't that
funny how Joe Scarboro all of a sudden
wants to bring and prop up no labels
look I'll talk about No Labels like it's
no tomorrow but I'm not going to be be
like well see listen the No Labels crew
called me and they lied to me and told
me that their number one goal is to make
sure Donald Trump is not elected
president well if that's the case then
back Joe Biden No
Labels if you're a No Labels group and
you really claim to be no labels then
you would support someone no matter what
their label right ain't that what you
think the No Labels idea would be that
you would support someone no B the
label H maybe I'm off my rocker but
let's keep going let's hear what they
have to lie about here Joe Scarboro and
Joe Mansion is that your goal I don't
think that democracy as we know it would
with stand another Trump Administration
so so so the bottom line is then why do
you [__] vote for him why do you
support him why do you prop him up then
Joe Mansion why why why why do you
continue this conversation huh why don't
you say look no labels No Labels should
be supporting Joe Biden that period
That's who's gonna beat Donald Trump
that's the Joe Mansion knows we're in a
two-party system he knows that he
[__] knows that [__] this guy is not
is not is he he definitely knows that
we're in a two-party system and your
choices are Democrat and Republican next
November for whoever the hell is going
to be president of the United States you
can Dar gar goddamn te Joe mansion from
West Virginia knows that you wouldn't
get involved with no labels unless you
knew it would get in the way of Donald
Trump being elected President Joe first
of all there you go there's their
narrative there there it is there it is
right there no labels called Joe
Scarboro and convinced them to have Joe
mansion on the show and push the
narrative that the No Labels the No
Labels crew is out to get Joe Biden
elected to stop Donald Trump get the
[__] out of here man you pieces of [__]
and you wonder why I [__] rail rail
against MSNBC and Morning Joe sometimes
you're you're confused by this are you
serious it's the same reason I [__]
yell and scream and call out tyt same
[__] same same [__] [__] this is the
same exact [__] right here when they're
talking about Maryann Williamson over on
tyt that sense that somehow maryan
Williamson is goingon to be the
candidate for President Joe Biden should
back out and all that [__] that sink
hunger and the [__] tyt crew [__]
puke up every day [__] you [__]
you forget whether it's Donald Trump or
Joe Biden both parties have gone to the
extremes right there it is there it is
see I told you oh both sides both sides
and guess what Joe bar Joe scarrell says
listen listen real close you can hear it
if you listen real close Donald Trump
being elected President Joe first of all
forget whether it's Donald Trump or Joe
Biden both parties have gone to the
extremes right
right right right if Joe Scaro had any
kind of [__] balls any kind of balls
and any balls for the [__] truth he
would have stopped him right there and
said oh wait a second wait a second both
sides are not the same that is [__]
that is [__] wanting pie people to
have a decent [__] wage in this
country is not radical wanting people
not to go broke because of a medical
bill in this country is not radical and
I would question Joe mansion on those
points [__] Joe mansion and [__] Joe
Scarboro and they're pulling you know
whoever thought Joe Biden would be yeah
he was a Centrist or Center Center left
but he was never what we call left left
but they've been pulled that way and so
many Joe oh my God okay all you got to
do is go over to tyt the Bernie Bros and
ask them if Joe Biden's a Centrist
if Joe Biden's a lefty go ask those
people go ask the [__] go ask the
Medicare forall and the people who want
to eliminate college debt even though
Joe Biden's doing that go ask him if
there if he's a lefty go ask the leftist
if Joe Biden's a lefty and you'll find
out how [__] Lefty he is their
policies and the Republicans with the
right wing and uh it's gone extremely uh
to the rights having another option
right now when people are so
disenchanted with the options they have
and repeating what they had before maybe
it'll Force everybody to come back to
their Center if they will Center left
center right where basically make good
decisions so oh oh okay so so the only
time we make good decisions in this
country is when Joe Mansion feels like
he's the center you notice that do you
notice how that worked do you see how
that worked Joe Mansion the only the
only way that he feels like this country
makes good decisions is when he's the
center oh well well well well let's all
just you know what you're right Joe
you're right [__] Joe and you're
right Joe scarber to have Joe mansion on
to puke up this [__] oh yeah let's
do that let's make sure that Joe Mansion
feels little safe and secure about being
in the center [__] out of here with this
[__] I think it's a good thing the
movement I don't know what where my RO
it's not it's not about me and everyone
everyone has this ambition my ambition
is how do we save the country
off the cliff oh really you think Joe
Biden is the best candidate on the
Democratic side to beat Donald Trump KY
K you are a [__] [__] so is Joe
Scarboro show is Joe Manson these are
three [__] that's right I said it these
are three [__] sitting around a table
look at these three [__]
[__] what in the [__] kind of question
is that listen to it again listen to it
if you spot the [__] here listen is
the best candidate on the Democratic
side to beat Donald Trump is Joe Biden
the best candidate on the on the
Democratic side to beat Donald Trump he
is the candidate on the Democratic side
caddy
K he is that is a fact that will be a
fact you dumb [__]
idiot to to act like there's anything
else is a dereliction in your duty as a
[__] journalist and someone who is on
a national TV show questioning a United
States
Senator you dumb [__] piece of trash
what the [__] is wrong with
you I'm telling you I'm telling you turn
this [__] trash off this [__] this
[__] right here this little [__]
Round Table of these [__] is no better
than Fox News
period period period get with it get
with it and call these [__] out
listen to her [__] question again see
if you can spot the [__] do you
think Joe Biden is the best candidate on
the Democratic side to beat Donald Trump
if you're in my position or any position
in America everybody should say a prayer
for the president to succeed every night
if they do well go the both do well if
not you got a problem so you got to
speak truth to power too oh
oh there it is Joe Mansion one us to
speak truth to power well son of a [__]
son of a [__] Joe Mansion has come
around to my thinking to speak truth to
power and he thinks he thinks plating
and pinning up both sides as radicals as
if as if as if Joe Biden making sure
that three [__] P this is what Joe
mansion's really pissed off about folks
Joe Biden made three prescription drugs
part of negoti
with the federal
government he's going to lower the cost
of three more prescription drugs and
because Joe Mansion is in the pocket a
big Pharma that pisses him
off pisses him off and that's why Joe
Mansion is on MSNBC this morning with
Joe Scarboro after Joe Scarboro took a
call from No Labels to make sure that
Joe Mansion could get on their [__]
show after Joe Biden reduced the cost of
prescription
drugs
this is this is a [__] campaign
against Joe Biden to continue to do
that that's what it is that's what it
is you can [__] say all you want
about all you want there's always a
motivation between this both sides
[__] Joe Biden reduced the cost of
three prescription drugs for Americans
and and by the way I don't know if you
caught this piece of news he used his
executive power
because Republicans stripped him of the
ability to have a decent [__] program
that would have delivered people debt
relief in this country from their
student loans in a reasonable way now he
has to do it peac meal and [__] use
the bureaucracy and red tape to make it
happen but he's going to do it because
Americans need
it he forgave n billion dollar worth of
student debt for firefighters teachers
and civil workers got it let me say it
again let me say it again to you out
there who have teachers firefighters and
civil workers in their family who have
student debt Joe Biden used his power
it's a lot of red tape but he used his
power to use that red tape to to cancel
n billion with a student debt for
teachers firefighters and civil workers
you know those radicals oh my God those
radical kindergarten
teachers who go to school and [__]
rack up tons of Lifetime debt so they
can get paid [__] at the school because
frankly Republicans want to want to
[__] bury public
education oh and those civil workers and
firefighters the people that show up to
your house to put your to put the fire
out on your house how dare they how dare
they think that they should have their
college debt cancelled you
[__] that's what Joe mansion's
pissed off about this morning that9
billion doll of student debt is relieved
and that three drug cost are lowered and
I've said you're going too far you're
pushing an envelope where people aren't
going right now you're trying to you're
way ahead of your skis oh oh you hear
that you hear that Joe Biden is way
ahead of his skis way ahead of his skis
oh my God you know what you're right Joe
Mansion the American people definitely
want to have all their student debt that
they were [__] duped into getting
they were duped most of Americans who
have student debt are duped into getting
it they're like oh yeah just go get you
a college degree and everything will be
cool you'll be rich like us oink you'll
be rich if you go get a college degree
it'll be great trust
me yeah how that work out for most
Americans it doesn't I'm here to tell
you it
doesn't oh but that's what oh Joe Biden
that [__] leftist that goddamn
socialist oh my God that [__] piece
of that [__] piece of garbage Joe
Biden helping Americans by relieving
them of student Deb especially
firefighters and teachers am I right am
I right Joe Mansion way out in front of
his skis and lowering drug cost how dare
certain things so Senator was that a yes
you do think Joe Biden is the best
candidate to beat Donald see see there
you go caddy K be a [__] again caddy why
you mean such a [__] [__] why why why
and she understands the word [__] she's
from a country where they use the word
[__] a lot a lot they use the word [__]
and it means a little different than it
does over here right it means a little
different than it does over here over
here a lot of people don't like that
word oh they [__] hate that word they
[__] when I say [__] that really oh
digs in their crawl they're like oh toon
can't say that
word cadd knows what I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking about caddy
you know what I'm saying why did she
follow up with the same [__] stupid
ass question oh that's right because she
wants the stupid ass question out there
in the narrative because no labels
called Joe Scarborough and made sure
that they got their narrative on their
program that Jim Biden is old and he's
decrepit he doesn't know what he's doing
he has no clue what to do he does he
doesn't know that helping Americans is
radical Trump uh if you're heads up
right now I'm looking at some polls the
same as you're looking at them right now
and they're flipping back and forth all
the time so it's a very but right now oh
oh wait wait wait wait what did he say
what did he say about polls oh man it's
almost like I'm correct again listen
listen to what he says about polls
listen so Senator was that a yes you do
think Joe Biden is the best candidate to
beat Donald Trump uh if you're up right
now I'm looking at some polls the same
as you're looking at them right now and
they're flipping back and forth all the
time oh oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I just like I said
the media is making sure that the polls
say that this is a clo close race so
they so that they can bring
[__] like Joe mansion on with
no labels who are trying to torch our
[__] elector election to throw it
towards Donald Trump because they don't
like Joe Biden because he's doing things
like like [__] reducing student debt
lowering drug costs making sure making
sure we spend our money on [__]
infrastructure here in this country
making sure we bring back jobs to this
country in the chips and and science act
making sure we give [__] veterans the
health care that they deserve making
sure that we give First Responders in
911 that they deserve that's what
they're [__] against and that's why
they do the polls to where that Joe
Mansion could come on the show from no
labels and be like well I'm looking at
the same polls you guys are looking at
and you know what it says oh boy it's a
close race back and forth Donald Trump's
got a chance to
win and the only way we can actually
make him have a chance to win is no
labels getting out there and trying to
steal away [__] votes to appear to be
Centrist to appear to be moderate and
independent and it's so far from the
[__] case again if you were no labels
if you truly were no labels then the
label wouldn't [__] matter Democrat
or Republican
Trump or Biden the label wouldn't matter
if you truly are no labels Joe mansion
and [__] you Joe Scarborough and caddy K
let me [__] you you little
[__] a a trio a trio of [__] this
morning on the mainstream media and you
heard it right here you I always speak
out against them but this morning I gave
you the [__] narrative I showed you
the [__]
evidence I'm sick of that [__]
sick of it to have to be spoonfed the
[__] on a on a network like MSNBC
who have good commentators they have
good commentators on there but I'm going
to be quite honest with you if those
commentators listen to that little diet
tribe that happened this morning with
those three [__] on MSNBC with Joe
Scarboro and no labels and weren't
questioning him to high heaven about the
actual questions that Americans need to
know about No Labels that's the [__]
that they should have done
done then to shame on you for staying on
that work Network or at least not
speaking out on that [__]
Network that's what you should be doing
just like I do here every single weekday
no matter who the [__] it is if you're
if you're hurting our democracy if
you're hurting the institutions our
democracy or that seems to be your goal
the buide [__] to let the fascist win I
will call it out every single Le [__]
time and I will do it again and again
and again to these [__] losers who
don't understand what this country is I
don't give a [__] what their polls say
and you're and you shouldn't give a [__]
what their plls say and you should stay
right here on the Tony Michaels podcast
if you're on YouTube or twitch don't go
anywhere Gabe Sanchez what was that live
is up next he's right after this on
Thursday today's Thursday October 5th
Gabe Sanchez right after this show so
make sure you subscribe here on YouTube
to the Tony Michaels podcast so you get
thrown into Gabe Sanchez's show every
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday what was that
live also follow us on Twitch go over
there on Twitch it's free twitch.tv
thony Michaels follow us over there as
well so that way on Tuesdays Wednesday
and Thursdays you can go straight into
Gabe Sanchez's show what was that live
everyone same time same place tomorrow
it's been great to see you you're the
best audience in the world thanks for
all the support it means so much to me
same time same place surf up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's meor head ass
speaking